Welcome back everyone this is my video for the
suicide squad movie ending and post credits scenes
obviously there's a couple post credits scenes
with a bunch of easter eggs teasing what's coming
next so we'll break it all down if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos i'll be doing a couple more videos
for the movie too like a full breakdown video
with easter eggs for the entire movie starting
tomorrow careful for spoilers if you have not
seen the movie yet it's on hbo max right now so
if you haven't seen it make sure you check it out
but starting at the end of the movie they reveal
that the real macguffin is actually a hard drive
full of data containing the truth about the
united states government's involvement in the
starro experiments throughout the movie they
spend a lot of time during several different
scenes hyping up just how terrible the thinker
is gaius graves peter capaldi's character he's
a new version of the thinker from the comics
but he's from the suicide squad comics and he
was based on a character that they never really
gave a name to but he's been performing these
terrible experiments with starro in mind control
for the past 30 years at this secret nazi base or
former nazi base called jotunheim I know i just
got done doing all these loki episodes james gunn
also a big marvel director with the guardians of
the galaxy movies which is a funny coincidence
that the name yodenheim shows up during a big dc
movie but they reveal amongst the rebels the other
locals on cortel maltese that it's known as a
place where the current dictator at any given time
sends his political enemies any dissidents he
doesn't like even people who just casually say
mean things about him they're whole families women
and children and they're never seen from again
so even though the new dictator who harley
quinn kills during the events of the movie
takes over killing the previous one and
they want it to seem like this really moment
they imply that the previous dictator was just
as bad as this new one either the united states
government helped put him in power and keep him
in power for the past 30 years or so turning a
blind eye to anything he did because of what they
were doing in this secret nazi base with starro
at the end of the movie rick flagg learns the
truth about what the thinker's been doing down
here experimenting on all these people trying to
create a way to control and weaponize starro for
the us government control large groups of people
at scale the way that ratcatcher 2 controls armies
of rats all at the same time flagg tries to
call him out on it the thinker says that he's
actually been on the government's payroll the
us military's payroll this whole time and just
to make it seem extra creepy when the camera is
panning around the room they show you that he's
been experimenting on pregnant women children the
elderly he even makes a joke about experimenting
on a journalist that they currently have strung
up who says some mean things about the government
and all of it was done on the orders of the us
government for the purposes of weaponizing starro
so the thinker tries to play it as if he's not
the real villain here like i was just doing what
i was told from your government even starro who
was supposed to be kind of the big bad in the
movie metaphorically and literally because
he is so huge you kind of sympathize with
him because he uses his mc ability to speak
through the people begging flagg to help him
escape and says the thinker's been torturing him
for the past 30 years as part of his experiments
and if it wasn't clear starro was not lying when
he was saying that even though he does go on a
rampage later trying to take control of the island
this is my city now it's only in retaliation for
the past 30 years of torture that he endured they
revealed the whole reason why he was captured in
the first place is that he was discovered floating
in outer space near earth's orbit by united states
astronauts then mine controlled the astronauts
when the shuttle returned the government just took
him to yodenheim and coto maltese and made their
bargain with that previous dictator putting him in
power so that they can conduct their experiments
on him in private they also clarify staro's powers
within the dc eu they say that as he controls more
and more people he grows larger and larger and for
the most part this version of starro seems like he
dies at the end of the movie but because he spawns
in a really weird way it's always possible that
a version of him winds up surviving and shows up
in another future dc movie at some point he can
always come back in the future but while rick
flagg is trying to call an audible here in the
basement released the data from the hard drive
to expose what the government's been doing to the
rest of the world john cena's peacemaker reveals
that he was also on a secret mission given him by
amanda waller to prevent any data or information
from jodenheim from getting out he was supposed
to ensure that everything was destroyed the base
itself including all the files and records so
while bloodsport harley quinn king shark the rest
of the suicide squad try to deal with the courtois
maltese army and starro himself peacemaker and
rick flack are having their fight to the death all
while yodenheim itself is crumbling around them
the way they play this though is that peacemaker
does not hate rig flagg but he's so committed to
doing what he's told to do by any figure of
authority from the u.s government protecting
lady liberty so to speak like protecting the idea
of what he thinks america is he has a knock-down
drag-out fight to the death with rick flack to
prevent the data from getting out in the whole
idea that amanda waller is manipulating him
because he's so thick-headed she'd been saying
throughout the movie that something was at stake
that would threaten to destroy the entire country
like early on they make you think that it might
be starro that she's referring to but really the
whole time she was referring to the data like
yestaro was bad but she thought that the data
getting out and the truth about the government
getting out would be even worse so in true fashion
the whole idea in suicide squad movies is that
there aren't any real big heroes although there's
some jokes about being superheroes or becoming
superheroes when they defeat starro at the end of
the movie polka dot man getting one last digging
at his mother the idea is that all the characters
in the movies are kind of villains just some of
them are worse than others even the us government
like the us government is kind of the real
villain of the movie secretly at the end of the
day because they're the ones that are responsible
for everything that's happening now but this whole
idea the peacemaker will do anything that
anyone tells them that's why they spent so
much time earlier in the movie having him say all
those funny things about eating all the dicks on
the beach if he was told to because they wanted to
establish that he would literally do anything that
anyone in a position of authority over him told
him to do unquestioningly then after he's killed
rick flagg and jotunheim continues to crumble
around their entire squad while they're trying to
not get crushed to death bloodsport just happens
to land right in front of peacemaker and learns
exactly what just happened with rick flack they
face off in a classic gunslinger standoff moment
paying off their rivalry that had been going on
since the beginning of the movie they spent the
entire movie with the two of them having arguments
about who was the better crack shot because they
both had very similar abilities they make jokes
about that too like you do exactly what i do no
i do it better they had contests to see who could
kill the most people in the jungle who could pull
off the most creative kills so bloodsport winds
up beating him by using a smaller bullet slicing
through peacemaker's larger exploding round the
bullet pierces him in the throat he goes down
and starts bleeding out but then wait for it the
post-credits scene remember comic book movie logic
nobody's dead unless you see their body bloodsport
harley quinn the other surviving members of the
team defeat starro r.i.p polkadot man the way
starro goes out they also want to remind you he's
not the real villain here either as he lay dying
he says all he really wanted to do was look up at
the stars because he'd spent the last 30 years
trapped in that underground prison bloodsport
does take the hard drive of all the evidence and
uploads it to his own private cloud servers with
protocols that will release it if he gets killed
but strikes a bargain with amanda waller not to
release it in exchange for everyone's freedom so
if it wasn't clear at the very end of the movie
even though they argue about whether or not they
should have released the data he did not release
the data so that's why amanda waller isn't sending
other teams of suicide squads after them but he
still has all the data he could always release it
in the future if he wants to any of the surviving
members of the team here that made it out like
king shark bloodsport ratcatcher 2 any of them can
come back in future movies we know harley quinn
is definitely going to come back in future movies
but then during the first post credits scene
after a short time jump like later that night
after they've already come back to america you see
weasel on the beach where michael rooker savant
placed him at the beginning of the movie in that
hilarious scene of them all trying to land and
then getting killed off quickly he pronounced them
dead at the time like the weasel's dead and they
made this big joke about how come nobody checked
whether or not the weasel could actually swim
but he coughs sits up revealing that he survived
and kind of looks around like where'd everybody go
confused and then makes some noises and runs off
into the jungle with that funny way of running
that we saw earlier in the movie if you guys
didn't know either the reason why weasel looks so
crazy and messed up is because james gunn said he
based him on the look of bill the cat the famous
cartoon cat who was purposefully designed to look
kind of horrible and funny at the same time so
weasel's still alive now living in the jungles of
corto maltese until we're told otherwise but then
during the second post credit scene this actually
pushes the plot forward teases the next big
project they set up the big peacemaker hbo series
with john cena's character another short time jump
later both john economos and emilia harcourt's
character show up at peacemaker's hospital room
complaining that amanda waller saddled them with
babysitting peacemaker is retaliation for them
all knocking her out at the end of the movie
preventing her from activating all the bombs
in the team's heads and the doctor asks them what
they need him for what's so important what's the
big deal with peacemaker and emilia says oh it's
no big deal we just need him to save the world
and that's their way of teasing the plot of the
peacemaker hbo series so a bunch of the suicide
squad movie actors will be back for those episodes
season one is going to start releasing episodes in
january next year and i will be doing full episode
videos for that when it drops the episodes will
just follow the continuing adventures of john
cena's peacemaker as he goes on more missions
for amanda waller james gunn said he's hoping that
they get renewed for season two but i think that
dc wants him back so bad right now for more dc
projects that it's a foregone conclusion that they
will do a season two james gunn hasn't really
said anything about his next dc movie because
he has guardians of the galaxy 3 that he's gonna
do next and that guardians of the galaxy holiday
special which is sort of a marvel version of the
star wars holiday special and he actually said
that that's going to be canon in required viewing
before guardians 3. we'll learn more about that
soon but it'll take place between the events of
thor love and thunder because all the guardians of
the galaxy will show up in that movie but before
the events of guardians of the galaxy 3. the whole
thing with the peacemaker hbo series is it is like
dc's version of the marvel disney plus stuff where
you have all the movie actors doing tv shows on
their big streaming service john cena's peacemaker
is just the first series that they're doing they
have the green lantern hbo series there's the
batman hbo series that's the spin-off from the
matt reeves batman movie i will be doing videos
for all those episodes right now i'm working
on my full suicide squad breakdown and easter
eggs video that should post friday make sure
you have alerts enabled so you don't miss that
and my marvel what if episode 1 video will post
next wednesday new episodes of that every week
just like my loki episode videos everyone click
here for that brand new marvel what if trailer
in easter eggs and click here for that brand new
footage of ben affleck's batman in the flash movie
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you in the next video you!